ihr buch hin zum digitalen buch ist
nicht aufzuhalten wir zeigen ihnen was
es bedeutet sieht so die zukunft des
gedruckten buches aus der roman als
blumentopf für die kakteen sammlung der
duden nur noch dekoration goethes
gesamtausgabe die perfekte unterlage für
kaffeekränzchen mit der digitalisierung
ändert sich die ordnung bücher werden
überflüssig auch das sorgfältig
sortierte bücherregal einst
unverzichtbar in jedem gebildeten
haushalt nur noch ballast
heute werden bücher tonnenweise entsorgt
wie hier auf dem recyclinghof der firma
marx in winterthur
das sind vier wochen urlaub noch das
frühe 20 euro gebühr milliarden
gedruckter buchstaben werden hier
gesammelt bevor sie in der papierfabrik
zu servietten und küchenpapier vermengt
werden
das buch als kulturgut ist längst nicht
tot
es ändert los seine form wird klein
digital und mobil in berlin fand vor
kurzem deutschlands erste messe für
elektronische bücher statt
nikola richter projektleiterin der
elektrik book fair setzt sich
leidenschaftlich für das e book
man kann seine gesamte bibliothek mit
sich herum nehmen dann kann es sehr
leicht kaufen nämlich weltweit
eigentlich per mausklick es ist viel
schwieriger in print vertrieb aufzubauen
digitalvertrieb und was auch noch immer
ein großer vorteil ist ist das digitale
buch auch kein platz im regal einnimmt
also jemand der viel liest hat und kein
platz mehr zu hause mit einem digitalen
buch kann das nicht passieren
jetzt mal ehrlich wann haben sie zuletzt
ein buch aus ihrem regal gezogen
dem trend zum trotz das analoge
bücherregal erlebt derzeit als
sogenanntes chalfie ein paradoxes
revival im netz das charity ist ein wort
hybrid aus dem safe also dem
selbstporträt und dem schelf außerdem
bucksch 11 dem bücherregal
man steigt in eine community ein wo man
gegenseitig sich die fotografieren
kommentiert bewertet da gibt es viele
leute die sagen beispielsweise dass sie
noch einige mehr bücherregale hätten aus
auf dem bild zu sehen sein
ein grund warum diese bilder gerade
jetzt auftauchen und populär sind könnte
auch darin liegen dass seid ja auch eine
große debatte in der gesellschaft
geführt wird
über den stellenwert von digitalen
büchern und über den sogenannten verlust
des objektes buch das gedruckte buch
sein stellenwert wird derzeit massiv
erschüttert
doch ganz verdrängen lässt sie sich
nicht uns geht schon noch darum dass das
digitale buch oder digitale text als
kulturgut ernst genommen wird
das hoffen wir dass sich das in zukunft
ändert ich bin mir auch sicher dass alle
die jetzt hier diese sendung sehen
digital sehr viel lesen also das
digitale lesen ist definitiv im alltag
von allen schon angekommen wir glauben
schon dass wir im moment in einer
übergangsphase sind die buchkultur hat
ja auch 500 jahre auf dem buckel hat
sich lange entwickelt das ebook sagt
mann ist etwa 20 jahre alt also geben
wir eben noch ein bisschen zeit geben
wir dem digitalen lesen war ein bisschen
entwicklungszeit die entwicklung hin zum
digitalen und vernetzten lesen lässt
sich nicht aufhalten
gleichzeitig trotzdem bücherliebhaber
den medienwandel die neue freiheit beim
lesen heute
wir können uns print und digital on und
offline in die lektüre vertiefen
diese bücher wieden zwar schwer und
verfügen über geringen speicherplatz
dafür brauchen sie weder strom noch
netzanschluss und sie sind zeitzeugen
die ihre geschichten noch lange bewahren
werden